das komme ich glaube ihr habt schon
irgendjemand irgendetwas also ich finde
ja wirklich viel alkohol bei märz ein
bisschen unter dem abbau geht ja nicht
verkehrt leute und herzlich willkommen
zu einem paintball community dingsbums
relativ schnell geplant war wir waren ja
zehn leute unter anderem neue hauptrolle
komme ungespielt den haag essig enorm
paar andere
wir haben dann den teams gegeneinander
gespielt und so und ich habe das am
anfang irgendwie vergessen aufzunehmen
die erste 20 sekunden tricks passiert
das geht jetzt dann einfach los wären
cap und ich jetzt zehn sekunden auf dem
es losging holzfällen waren also viel
spaß euch gefallen hat bisher solch
gefällt einfach enorm hoch gehen und in
der bestand seien alle almere wirkt gut
zehnminütige friedens phase und dann
schauen wir mal wo einst und jetzt ist
mein bild auch dabei ich hab grad von
verkackt fraps als machen jetzt geht es
allerdings auch damit wird er wir müssen
in den wald und klima kein holz viel
laufen es ist perfekt aber die kalender
ist relativ wenig also haben sehr wenig
platz ist sehr sehr wenig deswegen
müssen wir glaube ich uns doch diese
pace bauen weil also paypal modifikation
habe ich einmal vorgestellte sind
allerdings wieder eine menge sachen dazu
gekommen ich habe übrigens schon ein
holz
ich habe schon 2011 wie gehen sie denn
nach unten ist erhöht die chancen oder
jeder gräbt sie nach unten
macht da irgendwie blauen block besitzer
oder wir haben uns beide nach unten aber
neben verschiedenen gänge dann unten
denke das sollte noch mehr oder besuchen
ist eine höhle das hat also brauch erst
mal auf jeden fall erstmal sachen ja ich
mache workbench komme ich glaube
dahinter ist die höhle da werde ich
wahrscheinlich noch nicht erst mal ganz
kurz in rabat warte ich komme direkt mit
an humor eisensteiner mosaikstein
spezial erstmal spitzhacke ich mache
schon holzhacken also dass ich habe aus
versehen auch eine hohe gebote du bist
so direkt verloren jetzt quasi und für
die neuen leute ich hab ja noch bezahlt
gemacht ob ihr das mit webcam haben soll
die pvp action und die haben eindeutig
gesagt er ist ja wir wollen erst mal
stellen abzubauen
das machen die anderen schon das heißt
das schafft man nicht mehr doch nicht
schlecht die workshop genommen ist da
ist da steht hinter ihr
9.11
sorry mein einziger bereit ihr blog sich
gegenseitig habe ich hab kein
mitgenommen hier einer noch ist das egal
er hier schon mal kohle die du schon mal
unter die erde
weil wir müssen jetzt auf jeden fall
ganz viele sachen holen wir können ja
spaß
die sich in der beschreibung einiges zum
paintball modification da könnt ihr euch
das einfach durch lesen wenn die ganzen
crafting rezepte wissen wollen warum wir
hier jetzt so geil auf reisen sind die
zentrale ganzen wo bist du denn ich bin
gott cola von dann kommt zu unseren
notplan und stellt ja eigentlich rein
ich sehe dich nicht weil du hast ja kein
essen und ich habe auch so dass es gibt
einfach schon mal 50 prozent des essens
weil ich leider erzwungen hier ist eine
rolle heißt doch keiner will ok das
herangehen
lasst uns doch hier und mal sonne base
bauen oder ich laufe erst mal so weit
ist genau hier ist direkt hast du ne
steinschlag jahr habe ich spreche hier
ist eigen bist du denn ich bin
weitergelaufen
wedig kanada so wussten hier alles noch
da ja okay ich habe richtig laufe weiter
runter ich will nämlich direkt hier ist
nochmal eisen wenn du weit heruntergehen
wie wir hier fast gar nichts ich glaub
ich den baum erst mal bei fackeln
ich habe auf jeden fall schon mal acht
reisen das ist sehr gut ich baue jetzt
kurz was ab dann ich gab mich gleich
richtig schnell da unten
fnp
was also wir haben auch im fall einer
guten vorteil ich frage mich wieso die
alle gar nicht reingegangen sind
vielleicht haben sie auch an der
oberfläche genommen dabei auch schon was
jetzt auch noch als ja genauso wollte
ich gerade abbauen aber mach du das
machst du kannst ein weiterer grund und
kannst du dann warum lotsen jetzt
erstmal eine stein spitzhacke genau weil
ich konnte das reisen selbst nicht
abbauen auch mal nach vorne geht es ja
noch weiter ja ich würde sagen mit hans
jetzt wieder auf sind mops übrigens an
nenne ich weiß es nicht könnte gut sein
okay hier sind zwei ging ich habe ja
viel reisen ich habe richtig viel eisen
krass viel eisen ein minijob ich hab
auch liegenschaft killer ist bei den
gleichen durch monster dritten wtf
wollen wir uns dann gleich irgendwo
treffen oder oder wie man einer
oberfläche ich sammle jetzt ich hoffe
jetzt schnell durch die mannschaft war
dieses jahr kisten mit dias häufig ja
genau das kannst du machen
da die superidee da so vor welcher höhe
will ich auf welcher höhe bin ich auf 20
lies wollte ich nicht laufen eine andere
richtung
ja aber das hier unten sind so viele
gänge also kannst auch nicht in meine
richtung laufen ja so aber trotzdem
besser wenn wir erst mal ein bisschen in
andere richtung laufen gehen das ist so
spannend da unten erst lover solche
lager mit dem das ist dann auch eine art
waffen nein hier ist jemals ich habe
darum auch karten namen gesehen hast du
da oben wie ein ofen aufgebaut oder so
nicht das thema und habe noch kein ich
habe noch keine offene aufgebaut ich
nehme erst mal alles mit ok ich dachte
ich sie schon die erste durch gedreht
keazor welcher höre ich gehe ich gebe
ich glaube jetzt einfach schlicht mehr
gleichen drauf ich mit 12 7 los komm
schon bitte ich brauche doch nur spielen
so ist es euro oder weiter hier ist noch
gold hier ist eine menge lava gold habe
ich auch empfunden aber dass auch in dem
interesse in die lava hier reinzufallen
das gold habe ich ganz gezielt
dagelassen brauch mal war nicht ich hoff
mal ich hab ja den die rezepte offen
also wirklich nur ein dia und redstone
hasse ich hab nur gold mehr ich rappe
redstone zumindest schon mal einiges
gold das kann ich das potter
verbrauchern eisenspitzen das abzubauen
redstone die alle in der nähe ich habe
schon mal retten das ist schon mal
stellen die aber auch seine eisen spitze
kenne ja ich mache mir jetzt gerade
einen ofen hier hinten da wo ich bin
das gameplay und pumps sich weg hier die
bei dir was ja irgendwo hin dass man so
viel mit wie ich kann richtig geladen
glaube ich mal 15 minuten paar zog
genau so ist es ich weiß noch nicht ob
ich die katze nachhinein mache oder im
vorhinein ich weiß nicht wo sie auch mal
schauen
hier ist also ich glaub ich durch
aufnehmen
ich denke auch ist einfacher mit der
webcam später ich mache mir mal ganz
kurz schon mal hier packe ich drei eisen
da im ofen rein gar nicht so viel
poppelsdorf funktioniert aber dass ich
dann auch schon leise spitzer gab für
die ganzen sind die sind hier so
gefährlich nahe habe immer angst dass
die mir jetzt meine eisen clown zack
areals habe ich zumindest schon mal die
eisen spitzhacke beim bmz meinen jetzt
eigentlich mit mit öffnen clown beim
klauen darf man generell ich aber nur in
der gegnerischen fans nicht und wir
haben ja auch alle keine base
selbstreinigend aus öfen darf man klauen
meine sachen gleich aus wenn jan kommt
ja ich habe auch alles weggenommen
ich laufe gut auf lover ebene lang auch
an die 100 euro aber eben ich bin auch
gerade auf höhe 22 war allerdings gerade
da unten bei der eben noch für 16 schon
mal perfekte höhe für die us das echt
erstmals wichtigste dass uns die abholen
aber ich würde eigentlich mir sagen dass
wir die us aus
einfach nur uns durch graben durch die
gänge sondern die schon ausfüllen holen
weil da treten doch öfter auf oder ja
aber ich finde ja auch ich muss sie
müssen auch redstone finden ich habe
jetzt wehrt die vier redstone viel eisen
gefunden
ich erzähle noch weiter versuchen
wahrlich folge so nem einem halbwegs
tunnel sag ich einfach mal ich hab jetzt
auf jeden fall schonmal eisenspitzen
hayes lehne ich den diamanten hat dann
könnte ich dir noch betteln so zack zack
zack als redstone haben wir auf jeden
fall schon mal durch mich das doch genug
was sich hier sammeln letzte dafür zu
beherrschen brad brauchen hierfür
redstone brach so ein apfel musst du da
lassen falls du alle office i got
redstone brauchen wir für eine fackel
redstone fackel wenn man hier
waffengleichheit jetzt auch schon zehn
redstone das heißt ich wollte weiter dem
gang kommt schon kommt schon ich will
aber nun die eisen ist echt ne menge
lava erfasst verreckt ich will auch gott
fast verrückt er kam bei greven einer
von unten oben von unten jabel
hochgeschossen ich glaube ihr habt schon
irgendjemand irgendetwas also ich finde
wirklich viel alkohol bei märz ein
bisschen unter dem abbau geht ja es wäre
nicht verkehrt
hinten scheint sich irgendetwas zu
verbergen ich probiere mein glück
boston geschlagen
das ist nicht fair
das ist unfair dass es nicht mehr mci
expert.de was later
wer also ich finde hier ehrlich gesagt
hat nichts mehr
ich verstehe nicht warum haben die ja
man schon wieder sonne vettel allerdings
hat gesagt man darf
keine ahnung was teils los neun minuten
vorbei wieso also eisen habe ich
wirklich an macht aber ich glaube das
hilft uns nicht weil wir brauchen ja
wirklich ein dia für die base saison das
einzige wofür wir ihn brauchen
ja ich weiß nicht wie es überhaupt erst
dann machen wir ansonsten wie ich schon
sagte die druckplatte und dann einfach
irgendwo in den berg rheingraben an die
kinder kennt werk mit der ach so und
nach 15 minuten ist er geht ja derzeit
schon los ja deswegen sollten das haben
wir uns jetzt langsam treffen oben ja
ich komme jetzt auch wieder raus ich
weiss ehrlich sagt mich wo ich lang kann
deswegen lauf einfach irgendwohin
ich nicke und gab mich einfach nach und
mäster scheißegal ich eigentlich sehr
wohl bin ich weniger geld bei drei
leuten und das sind die cvp ist gleich
in 15 minuten den timer bahnbeamter
netze die los ist vor
dabei kommt eine sackgasse gelaufen
amerika reisen unbedingt relic da komme
ich hier bin jetzt wieder raus wenn er
nicht noch schnell den schacht entlang
glaubt hier noch alle lang gelaufen
in der hoffnung nach dem die us-kräfte
experte eher entgegen gekommen
ich bin jetzt auf dem weg nach draußen
wieder ach so ich will jetzt noch mal
unter gesagt wenn aufhört 13 god dann
auch so tief nicht mehr müsste ich
glaube ich nicht mitnehmen brauchen im
endeffekt gar nicht so viel eisen was
wir haben ist schon alles genug wir
müssen unbedingt nur oben eine base
aufbauen das ist glaube ich das a und o
man ich finde ich kann jemand und das
echt traurig
ich begab mich jetzt aber nach oben
nieten und einfachen die treppe nach
oben
einfach so angst vor greveler wenn ich
weg bin nämlich dann sind nämlich alle
unsere ressourcen haben wir verloren
weil ich habe die ganze rote farbe die
er sonst
ich bin jetzt gerade auf mein gott ich
habe hüften entdeckt von welchen aber
die sind alle leer
du bist ganz oben
fast würde ich mal so grob schätzen aus
dem bauchgefühl dass ich habe genau
überlegen ich höre ich bin 34 grad mein
gott 36 okay was ich mir jetzt auch so
eine treppe hier wird das zdf gut dass
ich nicke die verfolgung nicht schon die
frage ist soll ich einfach ich hab den
der ausgabe von ich hab den ausgang
davon
hier geht's ich bin schon irgendwo
verlauf soll ich schon unsere sachen
kräften weil ich hab ja ich kann ja
schon mal alles kräften die ganze
richtung machen wir am besten
wir mussten ausgang gefunden nice müssen
uns dann aber auch gleich mal irgendwo
treffen
na ja deswegen ich mir dann überlegen wo
kommst du da gibt es glaube ich nach
oben
ich versuche jetzt wirklich ruhig mal
einen blogger oben baut ist genau auf
meinen blog höhe nach unten
wie soll denn nach unten li wie dumm
wäre das nach unten bauen du sollst die
obersten zwei blöcke schon mal frei
machen als travel ist oder so dann fällt
er nicht auf mich oder sand ich bin
direkt neben dem chor sie leiste so ich
habe ja alles da wir müssen jetzt nur
noch in the works mensch ich mache uns
einfach gesagt mit dem erst mal beide
jetzt koppel stone und gram uns jetzt
erstmal raus oder würde mir noch ein
erst mal komplett club genau macht dass
man eigentlich wo haben wir denn die
linie übertreten
die sind doch alle unten in der höhle
unter treten ja woher sollen wir das
wissen aber augen irgendwo da ich nicht
unterschätzen
wir haben die arien tage treten
wie kommst du wieder aussiehst exakt und
ich habe auch schon die druckplatte
gemacht wir brauchen noch sand das ist
ganz wichtig aber noch gar nicht gut
wäre cool was sehr gut ich hab da wir
müssen sand sammelt das haben wir ganz
immer außer acht gelassen noch ja
deswegen das grabmal kurz hier so ganz
einfach nach oben sagt ja die gehen
davon aus dass jeder von uns nur neben
sich hat ich glaube ich bin 58 erst hat
das ist in sechs minuten 20 minuten eine
von oben
ich versuch's doch da hinten ist eine
wüste müssen wir wieder erst mal zurück
zur bedrock wand okay die haben schon
die haben schon so eine base teil alter
jan diamant gefunden wo sie sein
das heißt wir müssen uns selber eine
kräften machen
ich habe so eine druckplatte gemacht das
heißt nur wir können die und wir gehen
einfach nach unten kommen und hier
sozusagen in die oberfläche wie ein
finger okay ich versuche irgendwie sand
zu holen
ja ich bin genau hinter dir wir müssen
jetzt zusammen bleiben
das land weist ja ganz normal wüste
genau wir haben keinen das ist wirklich
bitter dass
ganz traurig soll ich einfach schon mal
anfangen die base zu bauen was tun offen
dabei ja wie vor mit einem hin- oder
wieviele gastein okay ich würde sagen
sie machen das hier vorne
in diesem kleinen mini werk dann
leuchtet diese gelbe festung nah am
horizont alte hammel herumgebaut sand ab
hast du kohle ja habe ich hab noch eine
kohle abgebaut dass wir unser verderben
ich hab auch noch 14 okay das reicht
aber für die ersten 100 200 300 500
schuss 200 300 500 so genau also ich
mach uns hier unsere pace ich mag hier
die auch so dass jeder erkennt dass die
von uns ist weil man dafür die gegner
die schweiz nicht abbauen
hartley für uns einen schornstein machen
das ist echt wenig zeit also ich bin
hier habe ich dabei ich glaube ich
weiter wo soll ich dir den sand zu
schmeißen
am besten zweite dingsda im zweiten
offen
sie liegen eben was mir behelfsbrücken
das ist echt ein bisschen haben sehe
nicht ein warum man sich darauf
vorbereiten können man nicht auch keine
ausrede jetzt einfach nur so er wir
haben jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal
einen stack sand also eines der glas
getrennt
so ist es
was sollen wir denn dann als nächstes
machen also da sind ich hab auch fünf
reisen wo soll ich denn tun bei auf
jeden fall alle sachen die du baust
tiere weil ich werde gleich die türen
platzieren kreationen richtung haben wir
ich mache schon mal eine waffe wo sind
die ganz sicher keine items soziale
rausgenommen ja alles wein am besten die
kiste hier rein brauchen ein bisschen
holz hast du holz weil ich muss alles so
schnell wie möglich rein tun wie so
nimmst du das eisen über haus ja das
kann ich dir ergeben ich hab das ja wir
müssen jetzt genau wir müssen erst mal
die tür hier machen damit die leute
dürfen nicht in unsere pace eingehen so
lange ich drin bin
das heißt du kannst holz habe ich beim
konzert in der base und die darf nicht
abgebaut werden steht ja in der regel
was soll ich jetzt machen holz sammeln
sag ich mal hier nämlich der eisentür
die nur von uns geöffnet werden kann
weil wir komplett rote city so das heißt
da muss dann aber so eine rote links
vorlägen habe ich schon fertig bob
betrifft so das heißt nur wir können die
machen und ich habe jetzt zwei dicke
macht damit sozusagen ganz gut weiter
schnitten was brauchen wir brauchen ein
viel zu schwer ist glaube ich das
wichtigste wir haben nämlich fast keine
rolle mehr so wie ich das sehe ich
meinen apfel rein und das ist falsch
wie funktioniert das dann vielfach so
trägt mal ganz kurz schlucken
medi kit wtf das hat uns alle
nein doch das ist auch mit rechts die
kammern machen aber der rechtsklick auf
medicaid und dann leuchtet das ja aber
da geht ja nur wieder runter so am
besten ist es man nicht so hat jetzt
noch so ich muss hier weiter alles
einschmelzen und brauchen wie gesagt
noch holz ach so nicht weiter ausbauen
da warte ich baue das auch wieder zu
bisschen größer muss ja wir müssen ja
mindestens zwei dicke wand haben aus im
kabel warum das team der weil es
plötzlich viel zu schnell ab du kennst
die anderen handy können dürfen nicht
rein
ja man sieht doch nicht dass unsere pace
wahrscheinlich sind meinen die nur diese
anderen bases ok gute vorarbeit für den
coup perfekt brauchen wie gesagt noch
schnell etwas holz bevor die dicht
kriegen können und ich mache hier liegt
das glaubst optimal commerce schon halb
voll wie das herz das ist nicht schlecht
so wie viel holz bronze denn du hast nur
neun sand gesammelt nein
64 sind im alter hast du den ofen
einfach so abgebaut
aber da kommt ja alles traurig ich
dachte schon wenn man ja warte bis du
denn da die keine bluttest oder siehst
du mich nicht ja doch gerade habe ich
dich gesehen aber viel mit früher warst
du das doch wenn du rufen abgebaut hat
das dann die alte frau war ich glaube
schon
das war richtig ärgerlich wie viel holz
bronze nicht viel braucht wirklich nur
pastis also ich sehe gerade die wir
brauchen
was wollen wir neben für eine waffe oder
verizon farben ist weiterhin gar nicht
sagen wir gehen sehr sehr defensiv vor
wenn die anderen diamanten aber jetzt
schon so lange base hatten dann werden
sie auf jeden fall ein vorteil sein
ja okay die erste waffe die ich mag es
nicht wenn ich irgendwo verstecken sage
ich mal so ein bisschen kämpfen
was haben wir hier weiß ich doch die
zeit vergriffen eifel alles klar beim
webcam
jetzt ist ein cup in katar okay okay da
mache ich doch hier den kattas ist
bisschen weich dann sehen wir uns
einfach in der nächsten folge hat schon
das feedback in die kommentare und
natürlich bei conny vorbeischauen denn
dort bei lukas ich sagen ich konnte mit
ihm haben wir die andere perspektive
also bis dann